hi everybody
i'm nathan and i'll be going over work
my group has done on
parallel algorithms for sampling our
presences in parallel
okay so our story sort of begins when we
want to look at
these sort of i guess the most basic
questions you can ask in computer
science when it comes to
you know you're given an object and you
want to query about it so let's say we
have a graph
and we wanted to know about i don't know
perfect matchings for example
sort of the level zero question you can
ask is you know can we find one that
won't exist
but the two sort of harder questions are
counting so how many perfect matchings
are there and sampling so can we produce
one at random
and for a large class of problems
these two tasks of counting and sampling
are essentially equivalent
up to a polynomial time reduction
but um once we restrict our
computation a bit further and you know
it the picture gets a bit more messy
specifically if we wish to look at
parallel algorithms
um so we're gonna be working in like a
pram model so we have all these
different processors and they're
communicating via some shared memory
then just as sort of polynomial time
algorithms are the gold standard when it
comes to sequential algorithms
there's something we can define as nyx
class or nc
where we have polynomially many
processors and the ultimate runtime
though it must be poly log n
so the total work is still polynomial
but it must be heavily heavily paralyzed
will work
and then so adjacent to nc is r and c
which is just
same context of polynomially many
processors and polylog run time but
we're just allowed access to randomness
now
so i guess sort of returning to this
disparity between counting and sampling
algorithms
there's a whole bunch of combinatorial
structures which can be counted exactly
via determinants
spanning trees are resonances perfect
matchings etc and in general
determinants
and sort of linear algebra is all doable
in
nc there exists fast algorithms to do
this in other words
we always have these structures where
exact counting can be done
very efficiently in parallel however
this reduction
in sequential algorithms was a
polynomial time some polynomial times
sequential reduction
and in the context of parallel
algorithms even though we have exact
counting um
whether or not we have efficient
parallel sampling algorithms it's still
unknown
and so our work will be focusing on one
of these tasks specifically
our essences which are this sort of
natural generalization of spanning trees
where
um i just form a spanning tree and a
dish in addition you pick one vertex to
be a root
and every other vertex aside from the
root must have one incoming edge
and our breaths are essences are one of
these structures which can be exactly
counted via
some determining computations and what
we show is that there's an efficient
algorithm
to sample our residences from a weighted
digraph in parallel so specifically in
rnc
and we sample these are essences of the
probability proportional to the product
of
the edge weights so
to do this we use sort of two basic
building blocks
the first of which is the aldosphere
algorithm which has been used a lot in
sequential algorithms
to develop sequential algorithms for our
breast center spanning tree sampling
and what this algorithm tells us is that
just do this task of sampling
once we fix a route all we have to do is
sort of run a random walk
and record each um edge which visits
vertex which has yet to be visited and
by the time every vertex has been
visited
we'll be left with some arbor essence
and it turns out this arborescence will
be distributed exactly as
the distribution we described before
where something is sampled but probably
proportional to its weight
and there's a few sort of um small
caveats or fine print when it comes to
all this motor the graph has to be
strongly connected and starting for
starting vertex forms the root and of
course this random walk turns out to
need to be time reversed but
these are kind of small details which
are not too important because i know
this is really cool we can reduce
this task of random sampling of arbor
essences to simulating a random walk
and good job everybody we have reduced a
seemingly sequential task to another
sequential task
but i guess here comes our second
building block where
work by tang has shown has shown that we
can actually efficiently simulate these
random walks
in parallel so he told us that basically
to generate a polynomially
long transcript you can do this using
polynomially many processors in
polylog time so as long as l is
polynomial this random wall transfer can
be generated
in nc now the general sort of intuition
behind why this
occurs is that sort to simulate um an
entire transcript of l steps
what we can do is simulate the first l
steps and the last l steps in parallel
and then sort of stitch these two
transcripts together
of course there's one small problem
which is um we
don't know the starting point of the
second half all over two steps i've just
somehow magically
decided that we're going to simulate
from starting from the source central
vertex in the graph zone but we can
overcome this by
i guess being a bit brute force and
leveraging parallel the number of
parallel processors we have
so this thing when we simulate these
last l over two steps of our random walk
we actually simulate
these last l over two steps from every
possible starting vertex
and then this sort of causes
polynomially many processors which we're
okay with
and then we stitch the correct sort of
random walk
ending to the first cell over two steps
and so this sort of lets us break down
it's you know a task in the test half
its size in sort of one time step per se
and that gives us the classic sort of
logarithmic runtime we wish for
so combining these two techniques um
well tank's doubling trick already
implicitly solves this problem of
manually sampling our
essences if the cover time of the graph
is polynomial
because then we can sort of just use
time's trick to simulate all these steps
and then
extract all the first visit edges and
walk away with our randomly sampled
operations
the problem is it's very rare for the
cover time of a graph to actually be
polynomial and
in fact when we consider these sort of
different families of graphs this is
only guaranteed for undirected
unweighted graphs
so sort of figure one on the left is uh
on
is an undirected graph which is weighted
and has an exponential cover time or
time that grows in terms of the edge
weights as opposed to any sort of
vertex count or size of the graph and
then we also have an unweighted but
directed graph
to the right of that which again has an
exponential cover time
but luckily um there's this technique
that's been used in a lot of the sort of
albus broader sequential algorithm
rhythms to speed up those algorithms
which we can also leverage in our
parallel algorithm
and this idea is shortcuting so i guess
what is the key idea of shortcutting
the key idea is that um when we talk
about aldus rotor's algorithm
normally you say we simulate this entire
walk but what we really care about is
just the first
edges that visit each vertex so in other
words if
we um let's say we simulate our walk
we're starting at e and we're sort of
bouncing back and forth
eventually right we don't really care
about our random walk going from e to d
back to east and so on and so forth
anymore because they
both e and d have been visited and all
we really care about is instead
sort of when a random walk is in this
cluster ultimately do we exit through
edge you know
bd or ce and it turns out that in
general given some vertex set
and we can fix a root and once we fix
our root then we can compute the
probabilities that this random walk
ultimately exits this cluster through
each of the outgoing edges
and turns out this computation is a
bunch of linear algebra linear algebra
is very efficiently doable in parallel
so all this
sort of machinery to compute sort of
fast-forwarded walk
can be done efficiently in parallel and
sort of with these sort of two key tools
of aldous brother and this idea of
shortcutting
we're ready to sort of introduce the
rest of our sort of high-level algorithm
before going into a bit more detail
so i guess our algorithm we begin by
reducing our graph to a
strongly connected eulerian graph and
this will um make our lives much more
easy so firstly this will sort of fill
out all the fine print that all the
sprouter needed
and so also um the eulerian property
will allow us to
sort of proceed our second step very
efficiently which is this idea of sort
of decomposing a graph into these
tightly connected clusters so sort of
finding those
subset of vertices which we can leverage
that sort of shortcutting insight from
these slides that go
into and once we have this sort of
decomposition of our graph into clusters
we can then use certain doubling trick
to compute these transcripts of
not random walks in the sense that we
have a transcript of vertices and edges
but rather
a transcript of jumping edges where each
intermediate state is either
a vertex or just some subset of the some
cluster that we know our walk is in and
we no longer really care about any of
the
sort of finer details and given these
sort of transcripts we simulate we can
then
sort of stitch all these transcripts
together and once we have
sort of combined all these transcripts
we can
ultimately have a transcript from which
we can extract all forces of edges and
then
hopefully walk with a randomly sampled
arborescence
so moving into graph reductions what
we're going to do is we're going to try
to say given some directed graph that's
weighted
we can reduce this problem to sampling
our breasts
with already a fixed root and making
sure the graph is strongly connected
and we do this by first sort of fixing
the arbor fixing the root of our
arborescens
um the markup chain tree theorems that's
basically the probability that this
root is in our breast vertex is the root
is the same as the stationary
distribution
stationary distribution also a bunch of
link can be calculated with a bunch of
linear algebras so we can randomly
select a root
and once we have our root then we can
then add some extra edges to our graph
and what these edges will do is ensure
that our graph is strongly connected so
when we
do our random walk we're not going to
get stuck and you know
everything's going to work out nicely
and because all these edges that we're
adding are outgoing edges from the root
and because the root itself um by
definition any arteries rooted that that
vertex must
not contain any outgoing edges these
edges we add to ensure connectiveness
are not going to affect the distribution
of
our resistances so sampling from this
new graph is the same as sampling from
the old graph then lastly we can rescale
edge weights to ensure this
eulerian property so ensure that that
for every vertex is some of the
weights of edges incoming and outgoing
are equal
and this follows from the fact that in
general when we mostly fix a vertex
or choose any vertex then if we take all
the outgoing edges and just
rescale their edge weights by some
constant factor
we're not going to change the
distribution of our resistances
and this is because sort of any
arborescence will contain exactly one of
these edges so
when we sort of scale every outgoing
edge by some constant weight the weights
of every operators get scaled up
and sampling is going to turn out to be
the same
and so now we sort of have this eulerian
graph and
i guess the first few steps we did makes
sense it's for outscore to not complain
but now that we our graph is eulerian
we're going to be um well set on our way
to computing this type of sort of
clustering or hierarchical decomposition
and
so i guess like what exactly do i mean
when i say you know we want to
generate these sort of clusters of
tightly connected vertices so if we look
at this graph
currently up here you can kind of
imagine that when a random walk is
bouncing around on this graph they'll
spend a lot of time bouncing between
edges d and e
and a lot of times sort of cycling
between vertices a b and c
so you can imagine that we can identify
these as the sort of tightly connected
components which
you know we're going to very quickly not
worry about edges traversing inside of
them
i want to know about edges that go
between these two clusters
and we can repeat this process where
maybe we look at this sort of graph of a
b
and c and then say okay even in this
graph we're going to spend a lot more
time bouncing between
a and b then sort of cycling around a b
to c
so then we can sort of decompose this
again and
so we can sort of continue decomposition
until we're left with only vertices as
our sort of leaf nodes and our
decomposition
and once we do this we can sort of
simulate the first few incoming and
outgoing edges of each cluster stitch
them together and
ultimately extract our essence
so then i guess here's what we want to
get but how we're going to go about
getting it
so the nice property about eulerian
graphs is that in general we can
decompose these
layering graphs into at most sort of m
cycles where m is the number of edges
and when we do this then we can imagine
maybe we can try to get our
decomposition by doing the following
so we sort of first decompose our graph
into cycles and then
we can sort these cycles by decreasing
weight
sorry that should be decreasing but once
you have these cycles sorted
then i can take this sort of heaviest
cycle and ask sort of what vertices are
connected by that
in this case in our graph maybe our
heaviest cycle here might be just the
sort of loop from a to b and back and
then the vertices connected by that
are going to be this set of vertices a
and b
and then that sort of gives us some some
sort of nodes in our clustering
and then we can consider the same sort
of question of when we take these two
heaviest cycles
now what are the um vertex sets that are
connected
and if we repeat this and then sort of
take look at all these vertex that's
computed um well they're going to be
sort of a laminar family or each sort of
vertex
these sort of set of vertices is going
to be
um each vertice will sort of appear in
these family of sets which naturally
form this type of tree or clustering we
see
and so this is all well and good except
for one small caveat which is um
we couldn't really figure out how to
decompose the graph uh
and decompose our earlier graph exactly
into cycles in parallel
that was a bit too hard there's a very
easy source sequential
algorithm to do this where you just find
the cycle sort of
lower the edge weights by the minimum
educating that cycle
remove it and keep going but that again
is kind of sequential
what we can do however is compute the
sort of idea of a loose cycle
decomposition where
we um find a bunch of cycles where
the edge weights when we add them up
there within some polynomial factor of
the original graph and then we can still
do this process then of taking our set
of loose cycles
sorting them in decreasing order and
looking at sort of the vertex sets which
are connected by the heaviest cycle the
two heaviest cycles and so on
and turns out this will be um good
enough for sort of this idea of type
clustering
to speed up our random walk generation
and then so given this um idea of
clustering what can we do
so let's say we wanted uh to simulate
this random walk starting at a
but we only really cared about the edges
that bounced
between the two for children of the
cluster so we only really wanted to know
which edges in our random walk are going
from
this set of abc over to d and e and back
then we can say we're currently at a
we're in the sort of child cluster abc
because of um sort of why gesture that
back in the shortcutting slide we can
compute the probabilities that we exit
this cluster ultimately through bd or ce
unless we can sort of simulate
the random walk up to that sort of fast
forwarding moment
so you can sort of imagine that we're
generating this transcript that instead
of looking like
vertices vertices vertices looks
something like we start at a
and then our random monster gets a bit
lost and it's somewhere in abc
we don't know yet we haven't really
flipped the coins or figured that out
exactly
but we have determined that ultimately
when we exit abc we exit abc through
some predetermined edge that we randomly
generate so
in this case ce and once we're in ce
that means our random walkthrough is
currently vertex e in this cluster
of d e and ultimately again we'll exit
through some edge which we can randomly
sort of simulate without worrying about
what the random walk is doing before
taking that exiting edge
and we can sort of repeat this process
back and forth for some
fixed l number and then that gives us
this transcript
and this process is very much analogous
to
simulating a normal random walk and sort
of at a very high level
tanks doubling tricks still works so we
can still
sort of use polynomial poly and poly
poly nnl parallel processors to do this
to generate this transcript in polylog
time
of course while we're doing this we do
do this for we do this for each of the
cluster in parallel so
while we are simulating i guess a random
walk on abcd
abcde up to the resolution of
the two children clusters we do the same
thing for each of the other sort of
larger clusters on a graph so we're also
simulating a random walk that's
currently on a b up to the resolution of
its children in this case this is an
exact random walk
um when we do this for these children we
have to condition
we have to search high we condition up
to every possible starting vertex
as well as exiting vertices for example
we condition our random walk
between a and b on x ultimately exiting
a b
either through edge c
a or a b or each of the possible
outgoing edges
and yes this is a lot of work but
ultimately this will be
you know if you don't think too hard
this is all going to be polynomial
and that's good enough given how much
their parallelism were allowed
so we generate all these transcripts for
each of the possible
i guess clusters in our decomposition
and we condition on each
outgoing edge and this will give us a
basically a big pile of
transcripts in parallel that we can
hopefully
leverage in our next step and so i guess
here's our next step
so at the sort of our highest level
transcript right it looks something like
um what i've shown down below which has
a sort of very natural physical
interpretation of
a random walk starts at a gets lost in a
b c ultimately exits a b c through c
e then bounces around between d and e
then ultimately exits through db and so
on and so forth
but this is just the parts highlighted
in orange so the part where we start at
a we bounce around abc and ultimately
exit through ce
that random law was one of the ones we
were simulating in parallel while we
were simulating this highest level walk
and given those two transcripts we can
sort of naturally stitch these together
now
and again this is going to sort of
give us a slightly higher resolution
sort of random walk where we're still
not looking at every single edge taken
every single vertices with it
but we still have a slightly better idea
now and this will be distributed
as if we were just simulating a random
walk directly
and so then we can repeat this process
again so once we sort of splice
in our slightly more refined um like a
slightly higher resolution random walk
transcript
you can then again sort of look and say
okay this part that sort of represents
bouncing between a and b a lot before
ultimately exiting through
edge bc again that's a random walk we
were simulating in parallel because this
is just again another random walk on a
cluster in our decomposition with a
conditioned
starting vertex and condition exit
vertex and so again we can sort of
splice this transcript in
and so if we were to keep on doing the
splicing process
sort of well ultimately if we were to
sort of keep on expanding every single
um i guess cluster that wasn't a vertex
i would have just described and spent
the past 15 minutes of everyone's time
describing this really convoluted way of
sort of walking away with a normal
random walk
but what we do what we know is that we
don't have to expand every single
cluster and we actually don't want to
because then we don't leverage this idea
of shortcutting
so by expanding if we choose to expand
each cluster
only such that sort of we get the first
l edges
that sort of enter and exit each cluster
we will end up with some type of
transcript that will be sort of mix of
have intermediate states which are
ultimately a mix between these vertices
for the ccc and then these sort of
higher um
larger clusters but the idea is that
each of these clusters will not appear
until we've already simulated a lot of
the edges that
are a random walk would take around that
cluster and that's hopefully
each hopefully the sort of edges we have
exactly ahead of time we're good enough
for
extracting all forces of edges so um
but we do exper we are going to sort of
be expanding each sort of
jumping edge transcript in multiple
positions so even though i sort of
before animating sort of inserting it
one at a time you can imagine that sort
of the ultimate sort of
dependency tree or recursion tree looks
like we have some very high level
transcript at which point
we're going to expand multiple clusters
with slightly more
refined jumping edges of sort of the
lower of the children
of that cluster in our decomposition and
sort of keep on this sort of depends
keep on going all the way down until we
our inserting our transcripts are just
sort of vertices
and naively this is going to i don't
know this looks like a mess it is a mess
it's pretty expensive but there are lots
of things we can do to speed this up so
the first thing we can note is that
while we're expanding sort of different
um intermediate states
in one transcript these are sort of
totally independent actions we can
parallelize that away
so then we can sort of only worry about
and think about the unary recursion or
like the problem of if we're only
expanding the first
um cluster in each transcript
um now even looking at this though when
we're inserting expanding the first
transcript and then
the first transfer from that all the way
down again the depth of this sort of
tree is going to be the same as the
depth authority composition and
in general that decomposition we have no
sort of guarantees about how balanced
that tree is and
so um the depth can still be sort of our
order and or linear which is a bit
um it's too large since we our goal is
ultimately a polylog
and runtime but again we can use a
similar doubling trick
like the one tang used to speed up
random walks
here and again the classic idea is we
can sort of coalesce the
top half level transcripts while
coalescing the bottom half level
transcripts in parallel
before splicing them together so i guess
sort of animating that briefly we can
imagine that
we can coalesce this sort of orange
transcript into the blue one while we
coalesce the purple one into the green
one and then
and then so we can then coalesce the
green transcript into the orange one
or the blue one
and so i guess to recap what we sort of
achieved so far is
this really convoluted process of
generating a random walk transcript
where we don't have every single vertex
we have
but we have sort of the first l edges
that go in and out of each cluster
and well as long as l is polynomial in n
everything we've described so far can be
done in r and c
or very efficiently in parallel so i
guess the last step is to say okay with
l being polynomial n we can generate
this transcript
and we can extract all the first visit
edges but
when we extract all these sources and
edges do we get our essence we want
and sort of to prove that with very high
probability we do
but what we're going to do is sort of
balance quantity which is if you imagine
a random walk
on this graph for each of the clusters i
guess
when this random walk is when this
random walk has visited every vertex in
the cluster
just how many times has it sort of
entered and exited the cluster or
and what we show is that for each
cluster
um by the time that cluster is covered
by a random walk
the expected number of edges which sort
of go between its children is going to
be
at most n squared m squared and
now with a bit more work what this will
ultimately tell us is that when we
choose l to be some polynomial
with very high probability our final
transcript we can ex
um will contain all verses of this edges
and allow us to um
sort of randomly sample this hardware
essence now
um i guess i am sort of waving my hands
a bit and covering a lot of these small
details but
um read the paper if you want to know
more
and like i started to recap we have
we've come up with this way of
generating a partial transcript and
using that to surrounding the sample and
arbor essence
so this is sort of a first baby step in
resolving this disparity between
parallel sampling
and parallel accounting algorithms where
we're basically taking this one problem
where
the counting problem can be done very
efficiently in parallel but sampling was
not yet known and well now it's no
but um i guess the disparity between
parallel sampling and parallel counting
still leaves a lot of open
sort of problems in this direction so i
guess so the closely related ones would
be eulerian tours which
are very innate sort of intimately
related to arbor essences and the best
theorem actually gives a
sort of polynomial time reduction from
one to the other but we don't know
whether or not that
reduction can be done in parallel
another sort of very closely related
question
to random sampling of our resonances is
given regular matrix can we randomly
sample
uh an independent set and um this is
sort of
uh proper mathematical generalization of
our essences and
those sort of graph theoretical notions
i guess another more another uh two
other sort of
directions we could say are very
generally um this
our work leveraged aldous brothers
algorithm and finding a way to use that
make that very fast and parallel and
there are other sort of random
walk-based algorithms to randomly sample
arborescences and specifically that's
wilson's algorithm which can also be
generalized to sort of higher
dimensional graphs and so i guess we're
looking again um to try to find
efficient parallel sampling algorithms
in parallel there's another direction
i guess sort of most and sort of lastly
most generally
there that was that very long list of
graph structures which
could be counted in parallel very
efficiently by taking a determinant of
something
and for pretty much all those structures
um parallel sampling is unknown
and with that we are done so thank you
so much